why thank you yeah she made peanut
butter cookies last night I
said she says no she was never a Girl
Scout but peanut butter cookies were
good they're
just um they are
[Music]
having
e
e e
representative D Simon
thank you for your
Indulgence Mr chairman I will sit down
shut up and
start so you're the first I am
oh
dear I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 1013 relative to amending the
definition of temporary alimony since
the prime sponsor is acting clerk I will
present House Bill
1013 and call on
representative uh Michael Vose to speak
to this he's got a committee um meeting
to go to so I will call Representative
up he has written testimony and I will
pass it along uh please uh in either
direction put testimony papers at the
seats of those who are not
here thank you Mr chairman and good
morning members of the committee for the
record I'm representative Michael Bose I
represent Rockingham District 5 the town
of eeping and I'm here this morning
to encourage the adoption of House Bill
1013 in my judgment the defin current
definition in statute of temporary
alimony is seriously flawed and needs a
major
adjustment I believe
that this
definition this 23% formula for C
calculating temporary
alimony as currently written doesn't
take into consideration the marital
obligation of both parties and their
relative abilities to
pay under these current rules for
calculating temporary alimony a lower
earning spouse may be put at a
significant disadvantage if the higher
earning spouse abdicates
his or her responsibility for marital
assets such as a house or other
property Andor the maintenance of the
family someone who will testify later on
in this hearing will give you some
concrete examples of the damage that's
done by this inadequate formula for
calculating temporary alimony
if you're the victim of an inappropriate
application of this
formula fighting that decision can
require the services of a lawyer and
take time and money in a time of divorce
which is an
emotional and financial stress for most
people now I believe that the committee
can improve this bill
and in my written testimony I've
provided some
written a written example of what an
amendment and I know I can't propose an
amendment
myself but if an amendment were to be
proposed the language in my written
testimony might be appropriate
language it might be appropriate for
somebody to craft such an amendment
should someone agree and present it when
we EXA the bill on the 5th of March
March exactly exactly and what would
this suggested language do it would
essentially change the formula to a 5050
formula instead of the 23% formula that
exists
today now if you were going to submit an
amendment to this
bill since this particular language that
I've suggested in my written testimony
only modifies the definition the term
temporary alimony you may also want to
look at other parts of RSA 458
colon9 to see if there are further
adjustments to language that might be
needed so in conclusion I urge the
committee to address this serious
concern to prevent future occurrences of
in the words of one of my constituents
quote a lower earning spouse is
effectively abandoned often with
children and with limited financial
resources and she must choose between
putting groceries on the table and
hiring a lawyer for a long and drawn out
fight and I thank you Mr chair for the
opportunity to testify to be happy to
answer any questions if I can
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman uh representative Vose uh
specific to your uh proposed amendment
or the narrative to improve the bill
what's the definition of reasonable
need in in your uh
guidance reasonable need I believe would
be a need that is fair and just to both
parties followup Mr chairman follow
up and relative to fair and Justice
would that be a judge's decision then
and not an argument of not an argument
but an advocacy of both parties
justifying what the what their
recommendation would be yes
absolutely thank you representative Bose
any other questions for chairman
Vos seeing none thank you and thank you
Mr
chairman chair recognizes Patricia
Davidson
the first requirement for giving
testimony here is turn the mic
on and I say that politely because the
last time I went to testify somewhere
they had to remind me so thank you thank
you Mr chairman uh my name is Patricia
Davidson I live in eping New Hampshire
uh I went through a divorce between de
December of 2019 and it was finalized in
November of
2022 um has anybody here been through a
divorce in New
Hampshire was it
contentious all right so there's no
personal experience the one giving
testimony does not customarily ask
questions of the
committee rhetorical then
perhaps I'm very interested in this
particular bill because my experience
with it was very unequitable
uh there is no particular language in uh
our SAA 458 uh that describes how
temporary alimony should be calculated
so in most cases the judge will use the
calculation for uh term alimony which is
the
23% however during the divorce process
spouses should be on equal Financial
footing no one should be given an
advantage over another given that the
parties are still married temporary
alimony must take into consider
consideration the marital obligations of
the parties and their relative abilities
to pay suggesting that the 23% formula
for term alimony orders be used for
calculating temper alimony is
inappropriate and
unjust keep in mind that unlike for term
alimony orders during the divorce
proceedings an honorable party does not
have access to assets
and the ruling for temporary alimony
cannot be
appealed the 23% formula is the lower
earning spouse that a significant
disadvantage if the higher earning
spouse is
unscrupulous it would be much more
appropriate that the marital obligations
be paid proportionally to income or that
the alimony be 50% of the difference in
gross income as described in RSA 5
45819 a part two the phrasing of the new
text says that the court can find
otherwise however that requires that the
lower earning spouse hire a lawyer and
have the time energy and financial
resources to prove that 23% is
inappropriate that gives the higher
earning spouse a significant Advantage
they are also given the opportunity to
leverage or Force the lower earning
spouse into an inequitable AR
Arrangement because the lower earning
spouse cannot afford to pay the bills
let alone hire a lawyer in my case the
judge applied the 23% difference in
income formula for term alimony that
calculation gave me a temporary alimony
amount of $
2,33 a month no consideration was given
to the fact that my spouse moved away
and left me with sole responsibility for
all the household bills after paying the
mortgage and the property taxes I had
$173 a month left that needed to cover
utilities care for two special needs
pets food food gas
Etc I could not appeal that ruling based
on the financial affidavits that were
filed with the court this Arrangement
allowed my spouse to save $2,000 a month
in an account from which he had removed
my name in addition to that $2,000 a
month he also had multiple voluntary
deductions from his pay including
significant contributions to our
retirement
account luckily I had a side business I
closed that business and found a
part-time job so that I could leverage
those assets to pay the bills both
household and legal if I didn't have
that business to to liquidate and
leverage I would not have been able to
afford a lawyer and I would have to have
accepted my spouse's final decree
proposal because of the financial
restraining order you are under during a
divorce proceeding I could not access my
retirement accounts I could not take out
a home equity loan or a personal loan to
bridge me until the divorce was
Final while my spouse was scking away
money and living his new life I drained
the assets I did have access to
wondering when they were going to run
out was 34 months from when my husband
left me to our divorce was Final and I
finally did have to settle that long dur
duration is a direct result of my spouse
Pro not providing Discovery documents
and the multiple motions I had to file
with him to comply and during that that
time he was spending marital funds in
direct violation of the financial
restrain order it seemed to be an
intentional tactic to drain me
financially if he had borne an equitable
financial burden I expect that that
would not have been the case do not
think that my situation is
unique I hear the stories mostly from
women in my divorce care and my runaway
husbands support groups the lower
earning spouse is effectively abandoned
often with children with limited
financial resources and she has to
choose between putting groceries on the
table and hiring a lawyer for a long
drawn out
fight guess what she usually
chooses I was one of the lucky ones I'm
here today and I had a business to
liquidate again temporary alimony orders
must take into consider consideration
the marital obligations of the parties
and they must put the spouses on an even
Financial footing during the course of
the divorce anything else is inequitable
and unjust will you take questions yes
because an amendment cannot be brought
before a
hearing uh but winking and nudging can
be should per chance an amendment come
to us that might include the words or a
formula based on 50% of the difference
between the party's gross incomes at the
time the order is
created would that be the kind of change
you might wish that is the kind of
change that I would like to see happen
yes well we just might get an amendment
that says that who knows thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your
testimony and I was going to say we're
calling up an old friend but I don't use
the word old so what is the term we use
here put your mic on for that for the
record uh Mr chairman I offer an
alternative strategy yes and ask that
you use aggressively mature we are
bringing an aggressively mature veteran
to this committee one whom we've enjoyed
before attorney J marel yes thank you
um the
okay I was distressed to hear the
testimony um
this woman I'm very sorry for her plight
um but let me first address the bill as
proposed and why it's proposed the way
it is and I can understand the
objections to it but I think part of the
objections to it come from perhaps an
incomplete knowledge of what the law
allows and that's certainly important
first the I was involved in the original
alimony reform initiatives and had
competing bills back around 217 when the
state of New Hampshire decided that it
needed to when the the child and family
law committee initially decided to uh
Overlook overhaul the alimony statute
because it needed work at the risk of
being somewhat Ser self-serving the term
the concept of term alimony was actually
mine it was adopted by the uh by the
court I had by the committee I had no
objection to it the original basis of
that term came out of the Massachusetts
alimony Reform Act which before and they
used the term general term alimony so
what I did was I abbreviated and created
the term term alimony like I said it was
later adopted the point here about using
the the current alimony formula uh
brings it in Conformity with the rest of
the statute okay uh the idea is is
that I'm sorry if this is here the idea
behind the original alimony statute
reform was that it would bring predi
ability to an alimony order and you
wouldn't be going into a court with a
wild west shoot him
out the reason why it's 23% was actually
the result of two prior mistakes in the
law that was actually adopted uh the
original alimony statute prior to reform
had a provision in it which allowed a
court to take into consideration the tax
considerations of uh of an alimony order
because at that point point in time
alimony was both taxable as income to
the uh to the recipient and tax
deductible is an above the line
adjustment to the payer uh so that was
an important tax consideration it was
omitted from the Reform Bill that they
uh ordered that ultimately became law
and the subsequent tax cuts and job
whatever Act was federally of
2017 eliminated the deductibility as
Alamo so the statute had a big hole in
it and the big hole was if it's going to
be 30% of somebody's income without
consideration which is what it was
before the change I think it was Senate
Bill uh 71 which later amended this and
what it did was it took the 30% down to
23% in the event that it wasn't taxable
because 30% was considered frankly harsh
the other things that need to be
considered and by the way so let me
address this bill and then if I can
address the prior testim the prior
Witnesses testimony I think it's
important first so what this does is is
that this adds predictability to the
statute the whole point of the entire
statute was to add predictability and be
able if you're a lawyer or anybody else
to be able to sit down with your client
or if you're asking self represented if
you look at the statute you'd be able to
say to yourself okay this is how it's
likely to play out and this is what a
court is likely to rule from so if you
bring temporary alimony in line but
nevertheless the exception that's
created in this bill uh specifically
addresses a particular need um so when
we look about using the the formula
which is 23% currently I'll speak into
the microphone nevertheless if you look
it's subject to the formula limits
unless a party seeking temporary alimony
pleads and the court finds that
immediate irreparable economic harm
would result If the percentage formula
were applied and the the court makes
specific uh findings so what that does
is that's the safety valve that I think
that the people were looking for so if
you've really got a significant economic
problem that needs immediate addressing
okay the court can simply vary from the
formula it's not that rigid um the other
thing that I think should so in other
words I think this will be good law if I
remember correctly last year the or the
year before the committee actually
passed it and I think it passed pretty
much as written through house and
unfortunately got stopped in the Senate
Judiciary Committee so we're re
reintroducing it this year the second
thing to consider um is and by the way I
am I we I will repeat I am
very concerned about the prior witness's
testimony it felt like she was uh dealt
with un it felt like she got the bad end
of an economic decision um perhaps a
lawyer could have helped her but let me
explain this first in alimony
considerations alimony is predicated on
need and ability to pay um so in other
words if one party has a need but the
other party has no ability to pay then
it is unlikely that alimony is ordered
now bear in mind the statute is quite
comprehensive you can find people to be
voluntarily underemployed if a court
thinks you're hiding assets or if a
court thinks you're hiding income it can
attribute income to you under the terms
of the present statute so it doesn't
necessarily have to be that percentage
number one number two if you're left in
a situation alimony is not the only
remedy you get in court so for example
in addition to alimony a court can order
a person who was financially able to pay
bills in addition to alimony or in lie
of alimony or any combination of them so
in other words you can say you're
getting an alimony payment you're going
to get this alimony not only that but in
addition to which I'm ordering you to
pay and then you name the bills the
mortgage the insurance the car payments
the telephone whatever else it is so
there's a panoply of um of reliefs that
are available to you if you're an AG
grieved party it it's not that exclusive
it's not everything in alimony courts
have that broad General Authority so
this bill should stand as it would and I
know I it's my opinion and it has wide
support because this adds predictability
to the the statue rather than have
somebody just walk in and say uh uh it's
what I think it should be at this time
in other words and it what it does is it
focuses the pleadings so in other words
if you have like I I'll repeat it if you
have some kind of immediate irreparable
harm that can only be addressed in
alimony tell us what it is you'll
probably get the
order and that's all it is um I'd be
happy to take any questions on point
any
questions from the
committee representative
Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Mark yes
um so it sounds like you want the bill
to stand the way it is and be passed the
way it is yeah I mean the idea of having
50% first of all it's 50% of what um 50%
of what of somebody else's total income
bear in mind if there are children
involved in a case as there frequently
are remember that that's in addition to
child support and by the way the in
terms of the way term alimony is
calculated which Cod which is codified
elsewhere in the alimony statute is that
child support is considered income to
the obligor Ian to the oblig to the
oblig I'm sorry to the in other words to
the paye so in other words um A and B
and
and a is asking B for alimony and there
are children so B is ordered to pay
child support and can be paid alimony in
addition to child support because they
two they serve two completely different
purposes but as the New Hampshire
Supreme Court found in Crow V Crow and I
think that's back around 2005 more or
less was that uh Alum that child support
should be considered as income to the
obligor to the oblige which is the the
person who's getting the child support
and the reason why is because they do
they do benefit from it you know housing
whatever it is and they do benefit from
that
so follow up sure um thank you Mr
chairman uh Mr maral sure what is the
30% I understood the part about the
taxes coming out of it so that's what
made it 23 why 30% as opposed to 50%
well that was that goes back uh that
goes back to uh the original bill that
became law around 2018 I'll speaking
into the microphone around
2018 and uh the 30% figure in there was
not something I created it was created
by another by another group of people
okay and the child and family uh law
committee adopted it the problem with
30% was that supervening law from
the tax code change eliminated the
deductibility of alimony so Senate Bill
71 I think it was from probably 2019 had
to go back in and correct that mistake
because 30% of a gross income could be
punitive if you don't have to uh if
you're not allowed to deduct it from
income okay deducted as an adjustment to
income which it was sub from the more
than you might want to know
Department um it created that the
federal tax reform created some initial
problems as to what was going to happen
with
2018 uh as to the deductibility of
alimony so there was this tremendous
rush in 2017 and 18 to get all of these
cases settled if you were going to be in
an alimony situation because after 2018
the deductibility of alimony disappeared
so ba uh so in other words you now how
to case you could not deduct it it was
not an adjustment to income alimony
served not only completely different
purposes but it was actually uh the tax
advantages made it strategically
advantageous for both parties depending
on the circumstances so for example um
I'll give you more in the way of alimony
based on the deductibility of uh the
alimony payment which is what it was if
we can do this and this and this so both
parties would get an advantage to some
extent okay so now alimony is basically
in the same class as child support in
terms of its tax advantage
status representative McMahon thank you
Mr chairman Atty Markel uh your
clarification um relative to what
the bill is proposing is uh just in
quotes it's temporary alimony correct
okay relative uh to where it states in
here that it ends on the effective date
of the divorce but if there's children
involved still expenses of the the other
party mhm is there a different part of
this bill that needs to be recognized
for permanent alimony no no um the way
the bill currently works the way the
statute currently works is you have
different classes of alimony you have
term alimony which is the most popular
one you have some reimbursement alimony
and uh you have temporary alimony a
reimbursement alimony would be it's
generally not seen too much but it was
used in the past as a way of reimbursing
somebody for example in Li of a property
settlement uh typically it might be
something along the lines and I'll
be I'll be
stereotypical uh one party puts the
other party through medical school and
works at a lower income job the other
party gets through medical school and
now is a successful physician and now
successful physician decides the
marriage is through well what happens uh
to the spouse who put that spouse
through medical school and that can be
remedied in reimbursement alimony that's
one way to do it um as far as the rest
of it goes the rest of the language is
is okay I mean there are problems in the
statute first of all we have the I mean
if I can go beyond this sir in answering
I'd rather you not and just focus
specifically on what's before us okay
I'm sorry thank you sorry one followup
followup and thank you for that I'll
take your class later like like to learn
more on this um the other question is
and this is for me uh is what is when it
says on a proposed amendment versus
what's in this bill not in the bill but
refers to it
23% of of what is that a is that a
greven or what it's the difference
between adjusted incomes uh usually what
courts ask for uh is an alimony
worksheet and uh unfortunately it
doesn't appear to me that the Judiciary
has created that is put on a website so
most practitioners end up doing it on
their own and what you do is is that
they will take a gross income from each
party then they will make certain
deductions for example who's paying for
health care and who's doing this and
that will be create a deduction and you
can create an alimony worksheet and then
you can take 23% of the difference of
their adjusted incomes and that becomes
the alimony order councel wearing my
other hat is Chairman of the special
committee on the Family Division of
Circuit Court could you shoot me a memo
outlining what a might a recommendation
from my committee might be to the
Judiciary regarding alimony worksheets
okay thank you any other
questions uh representative
long thank you Mr chairman uh attorney
Marco I I just wanted to be clear that
you're you're saying that the bill has
that the bill has currently W written is
um the way you like it with this one
here yeah yeah um iote it other than the
proposed 50% or yeah yeah no I wrote it
so oh
okay seeing no further questions thank
you for your testimony and with that uh
I uh adjourn the hearing on House Bill
10113 I would suggest the prime sponsor
with uh
co-sponsors um take note of the fact
that we will be executing this bill on
March 5th
and you may choose to bring in any
amendments or bring in an amendment if
you wish and so you've got a couple
weeks to work on that so thank you one
and
all okay are you uh seed
filling no no representative Fox and I'm
going to be subbing for the EXA which we
call seat filling oh
seat
welcome I open the hearing on House Bill
1192 relative to contempt actions in
domestic
relations
matters and I am going to ask if
representative D Simon will present that
to us and yeah I
know would you like anyone else to do
it
okay Vice chairman long would you
present representative
Damon's Bill to us please and you can do
it from right there if you
wish who are you speaking
to all of
us I'm jealous
thank you Mr chairman good morning uh
I'll introduce House Bill 1192 FN
relative to contempt actions in domestic
relations
matters and I have one card and
amazingly it is attorney J is it marle
or marel Mar marel I respond pretty much
to anything
so counselor please come forward and as
a matter of Grace your microphone has
been left on for you oh thank you
um I guess in terms of this bill I hope
everybody has the handout that was
provided um which one in particular well
there was a there should be four to five
pages starting with a bar news article
uh two statutes uh Dom IC uh protocols
for the Family Division in relation to
protective orders and
contempt and uh there should be a copy
of the number of case filings printed
for 2023 from the New Hampshire Court
okay thank you um I guess as an opening
statement here the the point of this
bill is
uh I think there's a real need for this
bill and the primary purpose would be to
ensure the even-handed administration of
justice and to clarify some things that
are out there that have been kind of
murky um for years because the issue of
contempt is an important one and I don't
think there's a lot of prosay who really
understand what it is and there's a lot
of court and I'm going to ask you to
stop please because we including me um
have been distracted with uh passing
papers out and we missed and what little
I did hear of it sounded pretty good so
I bet the more of it it'll be better yet
so could you just hang on for one second
please sure no problem
sir did you have do you have two of the
everything that came by okay good thank
you okay
are we good everybody
up one more
second we're good councelor please start
over Okay thank you um well my name is j
marel I'm an attorney in New Hampshire
and I've been practicing family law as a
career changer now for' been admitted
since 1998 so I've been practicing law
for a while with a concentration in
family law um and this bill deals with
codifying what a contempt is and making
the law fairer simpler and easier to
understand because we have so many
people who are
self-represented um I think it's
instructive first to understand the
history of contempt and if you look at a
New Hampshire bar news article which is
top there um it was authored uh I
authored this and uh it deals with the
history of it to give some background
it's an old concept and it really goes
back to the king of England uh the
anglo-american history of contempt is
such that it goes back to the earliest
references that I could find in law
review articles was actually to a
Shakespearean play in
1547 it ultim It ultimately became uh an
an offense in the anglo-american
tradition was actually an offense if you
disrespected the king you were actually
disrespecting the courts because the
courts were representative of the king
so if you didn't follow Court's orders
okay you were disrespecting the king and
uh then the remedies from that flowed uh
it could be anything from incarceration
all the way through so I provide that
for a brief reference and it also
provides um an article for you to read
view to get the idea of what statutory
standards should be um now when you look
at the bill when you look at it um
there's a number of different things to
talk about and in the family law context
this bill deals with a wide sweep what
it does is it deals with all of the
family all the matters that come within
the jurisdiction of RSA
49-2 D2 which is jurisdiction so it not
only comes in with divorce anality
custody of children actions for support
uh abuse and neglect
hearings uh DVP uh issues RSA 173b which
I'm sure we're all familiar with
adoptions so it is universally
applicable the um and when you look at
the bill just want to make sure I've got
it out here to review
it what it says is basically it defines
what a contemp of Court means it means
that you have to have an undoubted and
willful Disobedience of a valid C
unequivocal court order so these are key
things okay and it has okay now new and
by the way I don't invent this this is
New Hampshire case law okay uh so so
actually none of what's being offered
here is revolutionary or new or untested
this is all well settled
stuff um so when you look at it willful
in the context means a failure to act
means an act or failure to act that is
voluntary and intentional and not
accidental so it doesn't even
necessarily have to be
malicious okay it can be but it doesn't
have to be
um and so when you look and when we look
at section two uh we're talking about
how these things are enforced and that's
going to be enforcement on abuse Al
all the child support and everything
else within RSA 490d to now we talk
about where the burden of proof is the
burden of proof is going to be on the
party seeking the enforcement by a
preponderance of the evidence
preponderance of the evidence means
simply more likely than not it's you've
got the ball over the
net
um and and if you don't have just cause
as a defense for why you didn't and why
you didn't uh obey the order there can
the court May award reasonable costs and
attorney's fees to the prevailing party
okay now and here's a here's a point
which I think some people may
misunderstand we're talking about here
order the incarceration of a contor
until such time as the contamin complies
with the Court's order and uh let's deal
with this it's an extraordinary remedy
it's one that doesn't happen too often
um typically you see it in willful
refusals uh
and it like I said it doesn't happen too
often but nevertheless people do need to
know that it's out there because
um it just is and typically that doesn't
happen but but for example in
Massachusetts when you're served with a
complaint summons uh for contempt uh
it's noticed right then and there that
you may be incarcerated uh so what this
does is is that the intent here is to
provide notice for any potential content
there and they're out there uh that you
could go to jail for something like this
it's possible so this is
notice um where is it typically used um
willful refusal to obey a court order
I'll give you one
example um I had a case where we had
subpoenaed somebody in for child support
records and the party simply refused was
behind on his child support had a
lengthy criminal record turns out his
girlfriend was working for the company
that um he was working for we subpoenaed
their records and it turns out his
girlfriend was The Keeper of the records
and uh they would refuse to provide the
records now bear in mind this was the
same organization that we had
successfully subpoenaed records for in
the past on a different case uh we
brought it to the attention of the Court
the court ordered a uh subpoena uh
subpoena ad testificandum deces techum
which is which is legal g g for you're
coming into court you're bringing the
records and you're going to testify okay
and in there was a note that you may you
may be put on for a show cause hearing
uh if you refuse to comply show cause is
the step before
incarceration and what it does is it's
basically you're going to have to tell
us why we shouldn't order you to be
incarcerated okay so incarceration may
result um and I don't want you to think
that this is fostering people going to
jail it almost never happens in New
Hampshire but it's possible um so when
we look at it uh and nothing in this
section shall be construed to limit or
preclude any other rights comma remedies
comma or causes of action that may exist
under any other statute so when you look
at contempt there are different forms of
contempt and there are different
remedies so the court has a wide variety
of remedies that it can impose
so why should we do this okay a people
really need to know how to plead these
cases judges really need to know
standards and guidance as to what they
should be using in the way of doing it
it makes from the judicial standpoint it
makes writing your findings of fact much
easier because all you have to do is
look at the case look at the statute and
you can apply the facts as to why a
person is in contempt or isn't in
contempt um and then what the possible
remedy is going to be um one of the
things that I had noticed here was that
um the Judiciary had weighed in and um
it says that it thinks the cost of
incarceration may be a considerating
maybe a consideration um I can tell you
that in my research I have not
seen any time that the cost of Inc that
if a court was seriously considering
incarcerating an individual that the
cost of incarceration was actually a
consideration uh not in 500 years if
I've seen that if a court is considering
placing as a court is considering
putting you in jail now bear in mind
also in your handout you will see
chapter 10 which is violations of
protective orders and
contempt now these are not binding they
come out of the New Hampshire rules of
court from the Family Division um and
when you look at it you will see here
that there's a couple of issues that I
have to deal with while these might be
considered best practices they create
gism I'll explain to you what I mean um
first it talks about jurisdiction and it
talks about the types of contempt and
the types of contempt which are civil
contempt which is what this would be and
um what it talks about here it does not
in any way shape or form reference the a
court to consider whether or not there's
going to be a cost of incarceration it
would seem that if the Judiciary were
considered that to be that serious it
would have been included certainly in
the protocols it's simply not um the
other issues that I see with the present
Protocols are that they create two
completely different standards um if you
look for example
on let's see where it is the standard of
proof used under the um protocols what
they're asking you to do is use um
is use a clear and convincing evidence
standard but only for two things
violation of parenting and domestic
violence petition okay so people who
don't pay their child support don't get
that benefit uh in other words you're
actually making it harder to prove a
contempt okay and giving more due
process protection to somebody who
violates the court order in terms of
domestic violence which may have more
serious consequences than somebody who
willfully refuses to pay a child support
now bear in mind the overwhelming
majority of research that I've looked at
establishes civil contempt which is
different from Criminal contempt and
criminal contempt is not a part of this
statute uh is preponderance of the
evidence is the generally accepted
standard um so there's a there there's a
there's a um there's a dichotomy here
and finally uh two more key points
number one when we look if you look at
the statute in presently that's in place
it's RSA
4851 attorneys fees in contempt of court
cases that's should be included in the
handout what it does is is that it says
okay if one party can prove the other
party is in contempt the court shallow
word Ator attorney's fees but
unfortunately the statute is absolutely
blank on what constitutes a
contempt so we don't have that here so
why wouldn't we add that and put that in
so everybody can see what it is and one
of the other things that I think is
worth looking at is uh how important is
this well if you look at a chart
published by the New Hampshire judicial
branch that's included here is how many
cases that were in
2023 and if you look at it from all the
various filings adoption surrender
domestic matters domestic violence and
all the way through you're going to see
that there were a total filings of
15,1 155 cases for 2023 that's a lot of
filings in my opinion for a state as
small as we are and so
sorry okay it's on the it's it's on the
handout it's 15,156
so this is not merely an isolated or
inconsequential issue this is a
significant this will deal with a
significant portion of family law cases
in my opinion the one thing I was not
able to find out from the Judiciary was
how many contempt actions are actually
filed they're listed here okay or how
many motions for a contempt are actually
filed during a case while it's in
progress which is typically what happens
um the one change that this bill makes
from the current statute is is that the
current statute says that a court shall
award attorney's fees the proposed bill
says that the court May award attorney's
fees I think I'm respectfully suggesting
that I think we need that discretion uh
for a court to be able to determine
whether the conduct is egregious enough
okay given the uh given the standards
that are provided um I think that's
important and what it does is and
finally what it does is is that it not
only improves the administration of
justice but what it does is is that it
allows parties to effectively argue
their case you can say one party says
the other part is in contempt because
because because because because and the
other party can stand up and say I'm not
in contempt because because because
because because and then the Court
decides because these are basically
factual inquiries
any
questions representative long thank you
Mr chairman thank you attorney Mel yes
sir
um for part for uh parties that are
financially strapped
right would this better get them an
attorney representation knowing the
possibility of uh reimbursement so if I
had no money to to get an attorney the
answer would be no I don't have an
attorney right the the fact that the
potential
reimbursement would I be able
to uh would more attorneys be more apt
to represent people knowing that there's
a potential for a reimbursement um I
don't think it goes one way or the other
and the reason why I don't think it does
is because there's such a very high
percentage of people who are
self-represented
um uh
I don't think attorneys take cases
necessarily because they think they're
going to get attorneys fees in family
law okay uh you know there's a
difference and you certainly can't take
it on a percentage basis for the most
part um what it does is is that it
allows the court the
discretion uh because this and I think
it's necessary I'm trying to answer your
question yeah no yeah you did I I have a
followup followup um so that a higher
percent just Pro say so there would be
no reimbursement there's no attorneys fa
then uh and one more followup I one more
followup uh now you mentioned to uh you
recommend keeping it at May uh let the
judge decide if it's egregious enough
yes sitting on this committee for years
and and hearing from the family uh Court
uh committee um it seems like judges
give a lenience for you know I'll let
you do it once I'll let you do it twice
maybe so that's why I'm wondering if the
shell would
work um I in my opinion I'm seeing
judges with a lot of leniency so even
though something may be egregious maybe
not that bad um the may may give um you
know may may give a Break um you could
certainly do you see that yeah um I can
understand it um I can understand uh I
would certainly be amenable to an
amendment if it wanted to retain that
piece of the L that piece of the present
statute I think that would be fine um my
only concern was allowing judicial
discretion uh because they can find you
in contempt they can order you to pay a
variety of things they have broad
discretion as to the remedies they can
fashion for somebody who's found in
contempt uh and that's why I said may
not shall uh the question is how far
does it go
uh that's why it was there great thank
you any other questions yes
representative Greg representative
Grossman I'm getting there I'm working
through the G's thank
you thank you chairman Pon thank you um
for coming before us so what are the
current remedies that are being used for
contempt and just to so you're saying
that this helps Define contempt gives so
you and what are the current ways that
if someone is in contempt it's at the
judge's discretion there's not right um
well typically the remedy is
um order compliance okay I now order you
to comply and if you don't I'm finding
you in contempt and now if I don't order
you to comply I'll put it on for show
cause Okay so that's one way of doing it
uh show causes you're in contempt now
okay and if you go and if you do this
again you're going to be in show I'll
put it on for a show cause that means
we're going to put you that you're you
got a real good shot of going to jail if
you're not complying with my order
that's the way it would be uh the other
remedies can be as wide as the situation
requires uh it can be additional
parenting time for somebody who's
withholding parenting uh that's why we
say we don't paint anybody into a
quarter on this nothing precludes any
other rights or remedies so nobody's
painted into a corner I'm hope I'm
answering your question if I'm not oh
okay representative Bickford thank you
Mr chairman thank you again sure um so
what we're looking at is uh it's in case
law right with the exception of the not
right and uh and you want to have it
codified so it would be more available
to the uh you said POS which is people
representing themselves correct thank
you yeah the idea here is is that the
average pro isn't going to be uh on the
case law websites looking this stuff up
they're not going to have access to that
even if they type in contempt of court
they're not going to know what the
elements are and so this would give
somebody cause for pause because you can
click on a website you can go right to
the statutes and you can find out
whether or not you have a case for
contempt or whether or not I better not
because they will have a contast for
contempt because and so people can frame
their pleadings and like I said before
judges can now look at it here are the
facts here's the law the other thing
that helps judges is when you read
narratives they have no place to go this
is the really weird part judges actually
have to cut and paste their findings on
their narratives so in other words um I
look at it and I look at the narratives
and it says in contempt for and then it
be State V not in contempt because of
this this and this and they actually
have to cite case law now all you have
to do instead of cutting Pace like that
to put your narratives together all you
really have to do is just look at the
statute and say
bang thank you so much and before you go
when it says and other remedies that no
longer includes banishment to Australia
does it no it doesn't Okay that died in
the Atlantic on the way over thank you
yeah okay thank you sir and I thank the
committ and Council was presenting for
the prime sponsor as well because you've
worked this out now we go into our
three-minute drill testimony confined to
three minutes and Veterans of this
committee will know that you can say
your point very well in three minutes um
the chair recognizes Katrina Hinrich
from exitor to testify
yep I think I provided testimony enough
for everybody but I do have an extra of
somebody needs
it and we start I am Katrina again I
wanted to speak to this bill not in
necessarily a total opposition but some
clarification just because there is such
a high self-representation that occurs
so transparency and understanding of the
laws is definitely difficult for a lot
of people some of the issues I wanted to
address was
considering what what is a valid court
order what makes it a valid court order
you look at the US code of title
28636 it talks about the jurisdiction
and powers of of what a in our state a
master does or a
magistrate uh orders from the family
court as we know because we have a
special committee may have attributes
that perhaps improperly reflect what a
valid order is so I referen to the
2007 New Hampshire Supreme Court ruling
that talks about how marital Masters are
authorized to make
recommendations which though they're
normally approved they have no binding
Force upon the
court they are not judicial officers
according to our own
State stakeholder testimony has
reflected that such orders are not
signed frequently if not
consistently and that's gone over the
years we've gone back in testimony from
from critical
stakeholders so looking at that there's
a there's a possible conflict there I
think that needs kind
of sought out a little bit more as to
what the details and and actuality of
what a valid court order is for all
these
self-representations and then there's
also the concern that has come forward
about
consent whether
in our family courts the marital Masters
are actually getting consent as required
under rule
73 in the code
636 there's some other issues
um concerning the
hearings that they have to be conducted
by a district judge upon certification
of the facts and again there seems to be
a little conflict in what we actually do
versus what we're supposed to be doing
and then the final thing I'll draw
attention to is the preponderance of the
evidence piece
um there seems to be a large arbitrary
and a lot of testimony to the
arbitrariness of this and the rules of
evidence and how they are or are not
applied and overall the bill is a
mechanism to deliver consequences upon
domestic relation litigant resulting
from these
orders it just seems Pro students to
really dive into what is a valid court
order are we actually putting out valid
court orders according to both federal
and state
law I think a clear understanding for
court litigant you know is important as
it is for legislators to understand what
litigant go through throughout this
process and that is really what I wanted
to draw your attentions to
thank you with 30 seconds to spare um
anyone with a question from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony you are
welcome chair recognizes Dana alre who
has a lot of stuff to give
us that's not a technical term by the
way it says you have 18 copies of four
exhibits well there's only four handouts
and I wanted to make sure you had enough
copies of the four handouts thank you so
much three minutes starts now well so
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee again Dana alre NAU in New
Hampshire and I'm a father of four as a
very brief background I think that one
of the many things that went wrong in my
family law case is that my parenting
plan was never followed uh so I'm
sympathetic to what I believe are some
good intentions in this bill
uh with that said I'm very concerned
about certain specific language and
possible unintended consequences so
rather than be for or against this it's
my hope I can give you a little
constructive feedback that's hopefully
valuable and
relevant so with that said if we can
address specific language in the bill
itself uh so I think one of the things
we're trying to do is spell out
specifically what stuff
means and that's a laudable
goal so I suppose I'm uh one of those
confused prosay
litigants uh we heard from chy barkle
earlier and I'm confused about what a
valid and unequivocal court order really
means uh so one of your handouts is a
one
pager uh that says it's a list of
judges uh in the NH circuit court and on
that you'll see judges but you'll also
see a perdia marital Master you'll see
Senior active judges you'll see judicial
referees also known as retired judges
and you'll see referees that are
attorneys appointed per
RSA uh 490 uh
F5 and as a second handout if you look
at what the first circuit federal court
of appeals decided in Whit V justices of
New
Hampshire uh it says that uh Masters
have no inherent power but rather derive
all their power from the appointed
appointing judge or the agreement
parties agreement of the parties so my
first question is how whether and under
what
circumstances do the actions of the pur
DM active senior retired judges referees
appointed
attorneys
count as a valid and unequivocal court
order per this proposed
statute so if you kind of compare the
wit opinion from the Federal First
Circuit Court to an email written to me
on February 15
2022 uh so that's the third handout by a
judge in my
case uh she writes to me that she
suspects she was a
co-signer uh well what exactly is a
co-signer and what's the legal
definition of that
term and she also says she didn't make
any decisions in my case
substantively so what does that mean
confused prosay litigant do we need
something in this bill about the differ
between a decision that's made you know
substantively versus one that's not
because our non-sub substantive
decisions valid and unequivocal court
orders or not uh if you also hand out
for uh which is just a transcript from
administrative judge king on uh August
2622 uh he talks about cosign or
cosigned on page nine so you've got a
half a minute uh so you can see that on
the second to the last page that's the
corrections page so again cosine or
cosine um I think you said you owed me
30 seconds last time I did you're in the
bank go okay I think that's critical
because when you get to section four of
the bill
itself it just said the court well what
part of the Court does that include
attorneys appointed it will that the
federal for circuit says have no
inherent power does 4 a mean attorneys
with no inherent power can force
litigant to pay fees to other attorneys
does that mean prosay parties paying
fees to representative
parties and when we get to 4B does that
mean attorneys with no inherent power
can incarcerate people for how long in
until such time as the contempor
complies mean indefinitely you know what
if the contempts for not paying attorney
fees will you take questions and by the
way for the record you owe me nine
seconds next time okay uh for anyone
with a question for Mr
Al this includes the temps and
representative long representative long
yeah right next to thank you Mr chairman
uh just just for clarification uh so
will constitute a valid court order was
one
uh do Masters and other
judging um qualify under this yes was
two and uh prosay paying fees uh yes
three was there was there another one uh
yes so
incarceration uh and I just say that's a
pretty wide
sweep okay thank you any further
questions
you seeing none thank you so much thank
you the chair recognizes Susan bristen
is that attorney Susan it was last time
right yeah still is okay no
disbarment good morning I'm Susan
bristen I'm the chief staff attorney for
the office of Child
Support
um our office is um against this B
mostly because I think it's not
necessary most of what it covers is
already in case law I would also point
out that there is
a in the Family Division court rules
looking at rule 2.31 enforcement of
court
order um it talks about bringing a
contempt action in an open case and
bringing a contempt action in a closed
case it even mentions that there is a
motion for contempt a standard motion
that you can get off the website for for
the court which they just have to fill
out so it's not that uh somebody who's
searching for this remedy has to create
a pleading out of out of thin air
um one order uh one other thing I I
pointing out and this
is because my brain likes completeness
um
is I if
the bill was was was going to go forward
I would suggest an amendment um with
regards to um in line well starting in
paragraph Roman numeral 4 with regards
to attorneys costs and incarceration I
would suggest that there should be a c
for anything um other that the court
would deem to be Equitable because right
now it's just you can get attorneys or
you can put somebody in jail seems to me
the court should have the ability to to
craft some other remedies as is
necessary depending on the
case any
questions yes uh seat filler colum
kcom thank you Mr chairman my Irish wife
would be very upset I didn't pronounce
that correctly Kum I'm not sure that
it's an Irish name so will not tell my
wife in any case thank you you get a
pass uh thank you for taking my question
you mentioned case law can you explain
to me the difference between our statute
law and case law and how the case law
would Prevail over our
statute oh that's a difficult question
um case law um is usually used to to
fill in the statute comes
first um and that and I think listening
to Mr markel's testimony that he wasn't
meaning to really change the law he was
just meaning to put it all in one place
as opposed to case law sometimes when
you read it is a little bit here a
little bit there a little bit there and
you have to sort of amalgam IE it
together so it's an attempt this is an
attempt to sort of put it all in one
place so that everybody can go oh this
is what this is what you have to do and
not look in 16 16
places
mhm working on a few items in the Rules
of Evidence book with members of the
Judiciary where there is case law that's
a bit squiffy uh we're concluding that
sometimes putting it actually in
statute makes it clearer even if some
would say it's clear in case law would
you agree I would agree um and I think
that the that's the legislature's meant
to to be the M the top of the three
branches so legislation would come from
well your colleagues in the Judiciary
agree so I'm still on this project with
them any other
questions representative Bickford uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
person um you mentioned about an
amendment and I I didn't catch it all it
was something about other remedies I
think could you point out exactly where
that should go and if you don't want to
do it now I'll take it later well sure
it's it's in Roman numeral 4 It's So
it's talking about if a party alleges
and the court finds that that a party is
in contempt it goes on to list with the
remedies that the court May award costs
and attorney's fees order the
incarceration of the
contor um I would suggest that c c
allow you know other remedies as the
court May deem to be Equitable thank
you anyone
else thank you so much for your
testimony counselor and this concludes
the hearing on House Bill
1192 with representative D Simone as uh
principal sponsor and representative
Nelson and sidel from this committee
perhaps if they wish they may bring
forth an amendment we will be executing
this on the 5th of March and we will
recess for about as long as it takes for
the clerks to swap
positions and thank you so much we have
two clerks Here and Now an adjunct
veteran clerk thank you for your
help
sure excuse me Mr
chairman
EXC uh respectfully a couple of us um
need to maybe have a three minute break
before would that be possible to um use
the restroom
okay e
always know as English but U we don't
have much
so we know nothing more about
success those
that be
that's
[Music]
we're going to switch spots on you y
they can keep guessing be like a parent
trapped
[Music]
oh good okay good now I have a clear
mind I'm not worried about getting
my
e
e a male color you and I do that a lot
that it's not color I normally wear but
I thought and it
was e
hes between England and Wales so it is a
Welch Celtic
derivation spell your name
ma'am so you said English March m a r c
h s which is kind of a border territory
that goes back and forth they often
refer to that as marshes but not with an
S it's not necessarily wet it's just
Borderland I was my people come from the
English Scottish Marchers back and forth
you know which makes things very
confusing
right well that's where you go
starts think we do the same thing I like
to have it on
yeah
yeah no he is
doing yes Drew Fox is a Democrat
right yeah Drew Dru fox fox is subbing
for Gibbons
right Conor the clerk's plural would
like to know your
name he needs to know it too
open the executive session now on House
Bill
1261 relative to voluntary Services
Under The
Chins program and uh this is a an exec
session we got to vote on this so uh no
one testifies with the rare exception of
when the chair deems an expert is needed
simply to clarify things so I'm sure
we've discussed this in our um in our
various caucuses and here we go so who'd
like to talk about
this representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman
um years ago uh we already dealt with
this uh
situation uh in chins in and I'm not
sure
we passing this legislation will make it
better
okay anyone
else just if you motioned it or my
mission uh no we're just discussing it
one more statement one more statement
when I did ask uh legal council uh if it
was necessary it was explained that it's
already in statute
The dcyf General Counsel new Susan larby
uh said that the bill is unnecessary
correct um Lisa Mar Mario um who I like
and she's sitting over there um said
uh it really you like it but did you say
it was
necessary now we know okay thank you
I think it would muddy the waters and
make
things bad so I I'm going to agree with
Council and um agree that this is not
necessary anybody else on this
bill would you like to make a motion I
would love to make a motion love to not
just like but love itl on House Bill
1261 TL and that's decent
Simone and in my bipartisan way is there
a Democrat who would like to second that
you are indeed a Democrat representative
long seconds it any further
discussion seeing
none when the clerk is ready please call
the role the motion is
itl Jamon Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative bford yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative Connor yes representative
kulam yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes representative
L yes representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Fox yes yes representative Raymond yes
16 to zero now what question do people
like to ask at this
point consent yes any
objection and what statement does the
chair like to make at this
time
H it's on consent yeah that was the
question we answer what's the statement
I make at this point report committee
report now and when is a Dubai
in about five minutes well yeah and
where does it go first to you thank
you well we've got everybody here
um I have been oh by the way this uh
concludes the
um exact session on 1261 while I've got
everybody here we've been doing some
back and forth I've given people a
chance in the committee to volunteer to
do uh speeches and piis and you never
know if a bill's coming off consent so
you want to be ready uh probably the
worst preparation was a time in my first
year when the chairman didn't know the
bill was coming off consent and wanted
me to give the pi and I walked up and
said hey what's the bill and so he told
me and my Pi was Mr Speaker if I know
that the people uh voting for this bill
really were smart would I not vote for 4
to and I had no clue what the bill was
so we want to be better prepared than
that so here's what I've got on consent
calendar
1027 representative Perez be ready to
give a speech and you can pick your
languages amongst English Spanish or
Portuguese thank
you and the pi to representative Greg
1341 the speech representative Bickford
the uh pi to representative
Grossman 1511 the speech uh the prime
sponsor representative Hobson I will
give the pi or I'll be ready to 1590 the
speech representative long the pi Jord
Nelson 1667 the speech in the pi
me regular
calendar um representative D Simon have
you have we figured out yet which bill
it is you're thinking about uh coming
back to
committee
um is it 1111 or his other one it's
representative Spain's bill on
um excuse
me no the other one 1111 the reporting
of a
in 1189 I don't think it's on the
calendar yet 1111 is on the calendar the
other one
isn't it's the other one with
recording child support 1189 that's 1189
and that's not on the calendar we're
going to exec that on 35 so we can
certainly have a big long discussion on
it okay on
3589 yep okay now 1111 uh giving the
speech is representative Spain and the
pi is D Simon
who huh you
you um You
can call the clerk's office and ask to
be on the speaker list that'd be good uh
that doesn't come from me that will come
from you directly to the clerk and if
there any questions just have them call
me and I'll say it's certainly fine but
it'll be
good
okay
1282 the speech representative ball
uh who is not here and repres the pi
representative Greg who is here 1425 the
speech by representative Raymond and the
pi by representative
Nelson
1564 the speech representative D Simon
and the pi by representative
long 1564
and
1573 with the committee Amendment since
I ran point on all of this I'll do
speech in pi
1595 the speech representative
major and the pi was is
Bickford so what's
that is it
now yes it is indeed I
uh I will make that change thank you all
right we're
good next on your uh list is 1269 that's
a mistake we're not going to be
executing that today because there have
been a flurry of conversations taking
place with the prime sponsor
M M
M M okay this letters missing in there
um and so we're not ready and so he
could we do it on 11 on 35 and we will
so there's that
yes3
yeah doing I'm doing both thank
you so we've taken care of
126 one
right I open the executive session on
House Bill
FN uh representative posts Bill relative
to interference with child custody and
shared
parenting anybody want to speak to
this Mr chair yes
um in discussing
this
relative um
to the
parenting if a child is taken from his
or her
parent for two
years and brought back to the other
parent are we going going to punish that
child by not allowing that child to see
the former parent because the former
parent did the wrong thing are we
punishing the
child I I I just I think that this bill
could be
amended to remove that language and then
I would go on to where it says within a
2-year period two years a long time to
wait to rectify a situation I would like
to see it uh amended
to um 30 days so I would like to ask Mr
chairman if we could
recess the executive session on this
bill so that um I and anyone else who
would like to can sit with
representative post and talk to
represent ative post about an
amendment and it is your intention that
we would then uh finish the executive
session on the 5th of March we would
postpone that from today until that two
weeks
yes I believe that is
allowable representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman we do have
another bill that um was Prime sponsored
by representative cutab that really does
cover a lot of this but doesn't have
that um punitive aspect where it's using
the child more as like a a pawn so to
speak or as a chest piece in this so
there is another I I don't want to
duplicate bills we do have one that's
incredibly similar similar that has
already passed through this committee um
so I would like to look at that and make
sure that we're not because if we amend
this particular Bill we're going to be
like in step with this other one so I
really don't know if that's necessary on
this thank
you and for clarification uh this bill
has passed through this committee
already okay we'll get back to
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman uh as far as representative
deon's uh points
um the two years is so you can have time
to not have to squish all the time at
all at once for the uh of parent so the
courts have plenty of time to do that so
I I think that's it's appropriate the
way it is they we need to leave a
discretion for the courts as to how they
want to uh uh fit that into the both
parents time your point being on line 18
it doesn't say at the 2 Anniversary it
said onor before it right so it could be
a year it could be six months right okay
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for giving me time to
look that up so it was um house bill
10006 with Amendment um
40448 and it was passed through
committee
unanimously two weeks ago and it's yeah
my short-term memory being what it is
okay and you believe that 1006
adequately addresses the concern without
some of the possible negatives without
without the um extensive punitive damage
that I think would be more harmful to
families than helpful yes okay anybody
else so are we moving towards a motion
of itl does it sound that way thumbs
before we make an official motion that
we may regret okay how many think we
should go forward with this bill
OTP
uh that's not a thumb that's an indix
finger and she's
not well then uh
representative Greg would you like to
make a motion and write the report and
have us rise up and thank you Mr chair
you we we didn't answer representative
Damon's question of you didn't ask about
that to wait you said either OTP or itl
okay third thank you very much how many
of you would like to wait two
weeks one
two
four all right since that's not official
um what amendment might be brought
forth in two weeks
so those of you who are thinking of an
amendment in two weeks what what do you
got that the others might either be
modified by or
not I know you're doing some research
there yeah I was
um I just would like to do a side by
side with representative kab's Bill and
representative posts Bill and work with
representative post to make sure that
her is issues are being addressed in the
katab bill and the katab issues are only
going to be enhanced by the post
bill before I vote one way or the other
on the post
Bill anybody object to holding our
horses for two weeks
uh could we have a um I'm not sure if we
need a motion can it be just a request
of the chair that we postpone two weeks
um I believe Mr chair you can recess
until March 5th until when until March
5th March 5th okay the chair so orders
we will recess this for um until three
five thank
you thank you for the Indulgence of the
committee and Mr chair oh thank the
committee for their
Indulgence acting former acting
clerk be even
better got it and then we've got the
answer to this we we can do side by
sides and you can craft what you wish
and be
ready the uh chair now opens the
um exact session on
cacr
17 and you will remember that I
fantasized a great committee coming
together to try to meld the two
into um 17 + 25 divided by two and that
never happened that just plain didn't
happen we didn't get to it
apologies
um so we start with with cacr 17 on the
rights of parents that primary sponsor
is representative
cordelli uh who is here in case there's
technical
questions um so we're opening that
hearing on cacr 17 we will have a
hearing on 25 uh
shortly and what would anybody like to
share with the committee on this
cacr
17 and you can make comparisons to 25 if
you wish because both are in play uh
representative
deimon thank you Mr chair I think that
uh reading both of the ccrs um and going
over the content of both cacr
17 seems to address the parental rights
and protect the children children at the
same
time I think it's uh they're both well
thought out I applaud both of the
sponsors I'm just more amenable to the
fact that cacr
17 um that is the representative
cordelli um
cacr I think it's more complete it it
takes more of the fundamental rights
into consideration and I'm just more
comfortable with
it
okay anybody
else yes representative
L thank you Mr chairman uh couple things
uh one is last
year um last year we had this battle on
the house floor um that's one thing uh
the pertaining to uh 17 the um on lines
uh s
and8 um would end life or otherwise
physically harm a child um Psy I'm
thinking psychological or emotional
which testimony we were told that those
would
still uh apply speaking with attorneys
um they're not together with those
statutes still applying
uh so that's one issue I have with that
and also direct to
insert uh on number three starting on 11
uh director insert in their warrants uh
municipalities don't have warrants where
are you uh on uh line 11 line 11 okay
yeah number
three uh to add this uh to add this
question uh via warrant um I I know
there was some I know there's a statute
that sort of brings that all together
with respect to references of city and
towns but I don't know if warrants uh if
it if warrants are addressed in that
okay thank
you uh the prime sponsors out of the
room uh taking a phone call anybody else
representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman every time uh a parental Bill
of Rights comes up I always ask the
question do parental rights already
exist and the answer that I get again
and again and again is that in fact they
do the problem I have with this bill and
all parental rights bills is it gives a
false impression to the public that uh
they do not have parental rights when in
fact they do um I think it's it's a bit
deceptive um when parents feel that
their rights the rights that they have
have been violated it would be better
for us to direct them as to where their
concerns can be
remedied otherwise we put into statute
something that already exists they think
they have new rights and are emboldened
when in fact they have nothing more so I
do see it as a bit deceptive and I'd
like us to encourage parents to go to
where they need to go to to remedy the
fact when they think their rights are
violated thank you anyone
else uh representative Raymond thank you
Mr chairman um first of all I'd like to
say I agree with representative desimon
about her analysis of the the two bills
the compare and contrast um I think that
um the cordelli version is um more
appropriate than the uh other version
the cacr 25 um however my concern is
with the language on lines um five six
and seven um and and that says uh
neither the state nor any political
subdivision shall infringe on these
rights without demonstrating that its
compelling governmental interest as
applied to the person is of the highest
order and not otherwise served currently
well we know that the highest order and
compelling governmental interest is the
absolute highest burden of proof that
there is um so that is much higher than
everything else earlier today we had um
an attorney in here talking about the
differ
between um a preponderance of the
evidence um versus I forget what the
other thing what the other phrase was um
and he was supporting changing it to a
propon of the evidence because he felt
like that was a more appropriate civil
thing this we're now saying instead of a
preponderance of the evidence for dcyf
to intervene in cases we're going to say
it has to be of the
highest um order in order for DCF to
intervene my concern is even though
they've indicated in the line this be
shall not be construed to apply to uh a
decision that would end life or
physically harm a child my concern is
this is going to interfere with dcf's
ability to assess and intervene in cases
where um there is suspected child abuse
or not or mal treatment I'm also
concerned because the carve out is only
for murdering your child or physically
injuring your child but it doesn't say
anything about your other decisions that
impact your child's health and
well-being so what if I was neglecting
my child what if I decided that my right
to direct the upbringing education and
care of my child was to tell my
14-year-old that they need to drop out
of school and go to work
full-time does the government have a
compelling interest of the highest order
to prevent me from doing that the
Supreme Court says no we don't under
that stat that level of scrutiny that's
why for example Amish people in
Pennsylvania are allowed to pull their
children out of school at 14 even though
Pennsylvania has a loss saying that
there's compulsory education until 18 so
my concern is that we're banding about
these legal terms that we don't fully
understand the ramifications of and so
unless there is some sort of amendment
that would assure us that this would not
open the door to trafficking um neglect
psychological or emotional neglect of
children I I just can't support putting
something in our Constitution that is
not going to be in the best interest of
child well-being the chair would ask if
retired Supreme Court Justice chief
justice and current Judiciary chairman
Robert Lynn would care to come up and
comment on the narrow question of
highest burden in lines 5 to7 here what
does that give what does that remove if
you would sir
well I guess what I would say is I mean
it's certainly true that that is you
know compelling State interest is is the
is sort of the highest uh burden that um
that legislation would have to meet to
um to survive a constitutional challenge
for example if this if this amendment
were if this amendment were adopted um
and given the uh you know I I tend to
think that that the the example given I
mean there is a US Supreme Court case
dealing with the Amish children in
Pensylvania um that that says what what
she indicated um so that I mean it that
would seem to indicate that that would
not be a compelling State interest but I
do think I mean my sense is that having
that
standard is appropriate
because um it
parental rights are very very important
and it seems to me that the state should
be able to
interfere with those rights only when it
has a very very important reason for
doing so and I you know I although
it we all might say you know we all
might sort
of individually question you know is it
really is it really the right decision
for promish people in that example to
say their kids can leave school at
14 you know I don't think I wouldn't
make that decision I suspect that most
of you wouldn't either but I I guess I
do agree in the ultimately with the
Supreme Court decision it is that it
seems to me that you know they given the
religion the religious Traditions that
they have in that in that Faith that's
um I I don't think that the government
should be second guessing that uh
however you know ever much I might
personally not be one that would make
that choice so does the rest of the
sentence that say and not otherwise
served give DCF and OCA uh opportunity
to inter
intervene uh in some of the cases that
are not murder that we could see
happening oh sure yes I mean I would yes
for sure which certainly it would seem
to me that you know I I would not in any
way uh inter if you P if this
Constitutional Amendment past I would
not in any way say that that you know
um prevents DCF from investigating child
abuse or uh or neglect or any of those
things
um that would be my view anyway so that
additional phrase perhaps would address
what representative Raymond's concern
was with the words highest
order right I think so I mean I would
not you know I as I say I would not in
any way uh interpret that to mean
that you
know for lack of a better term ordinary
Child Protective Services because I
think those things are you know those
things are of the highest
order any questions uh for you while
you're up here representative
grossan well done chairman well
done um well it wouldn't prevent them
from investigating but would it prevent
them from having
findings gez I would think not I mean I
you know if the I mean you know let me
let me let me give you this example
which I again you know that obviously
any of these things in the area of
constitutional law it really depends on
the particular facts and circumstances
so it's hard to give a you know this is
the right answer I but but for
example
um if if this if this Constitutional
Amendment were in
effect perhaps it gives more um more
weight to a parents claim that
um there's only so far the state can go
in becoming kind of a nanny State uh you
know in other words I just just to give
an example when you know when I was a
kid when I was a kid and that's a long
time ago for sure but when I was a kid
you know I uh I walked to school
probably starting when I was I don't
know maybe you know six years old or so
I think I'm pretty sure I walked to
school when I was in first or second
grade and it was you know it was three
or four blocks away uh in a in
a so well I don't know if I call it so
the it wasn't it wasn't Center City but
it was a it was a sort of a residential
area of a city um and and I did that
along with all the other kids now you
know there's I I I think there's some
people might say that's you know that's
abusive that's uh too much becoming that
you you're you're you're letting your
child have too much Freedom too
young maybe you know this this if this
Constitutional Amendment were in effect
maybe it adds some weight to the parents
argument that um uh this you know it's
my decision to decide whether I'm it you
know when my child is old enough to be
able to walk to school that's the one
example representative long thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um so to that to that same point would
educational
neglect be the same thing that they
would weigh more on the parent
as to what the parent senses
is the educational capacity of their
child or lack
of I mean to if you're saying would it
you know would this Constitutional
Amendment weigh have a be weighed in the
balance if it were if it were in effect
yes it would I as I say I don't think
that it would that it would mean that
you know
outside of the sort of Amish culture or
maybe some other you know deeply
historical religious kind of thing uh I
think if you know if if if I just
decided you know I want my I want my kid
going to work in the factory at uh at 14
years old uh because education isn't
very important I would tend to say that
the state would have a would have their
compulsory uh education laws would would
that view on my
part okay thank
you thank you so much for your expert
Tes well I'm sure how expert it was but
thank whoops
sorry
more I missed your hand sorry I I'm
sorry I no thank you um I don't have a
question I just have a statement thank
you all right no no problem thank you
very
much representative Nelson with a
statement sorry I some bad
timing um as we've seen um and heard um
regarding other Constitutional Amendment
um
cacr uh that are coming through um our
legislation um one of the things that
I've heard from both sides is that our
constituents and our voters find it
important so why don't we have them uh
give them the ability to vote um and I
agree with that and there was a Granite
State
poll uh conducted by the University of
New Hampshire Survey Center recently
that found voters are split on whether
they generally support a parents Bill of
Rights
cacr I I think would fall under this uh
poll as well 41 to 39% but amongst
parents with children in the household
support for the legislation is an
overwhelmingly 58 to 22% so I think that
it's it's a great idea for us to um ask
the
voters that if it's important to
them and unlike last year when it was a
bill this is a cacr the burden of proof
or the burden of Passage is much
higher anyone
else you representative long thank you
Mr chairman yeah just with respect to
that um Hampshire is not a referendum
State um because let the voters vote on
every everything we pass here would
would be the scenario
um and now where were those numbers uh
the 58
something thank you for the question
um among parents with children in the
household
the number is 58% in favor 22% not in
favor um in general the numbers were 49
41 to
39% was that a poll or it it comes from
the granite state poll a states of
opinion project conducted by the
University of New Hampshire Survey
Center okay thank you representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman I might be
confused and so I ask sincerely what new
rights would parents get other than what
they already have I just need to know
exactly what rights that parents don't
currently have will this afford them I
think you know if we put this on the
ballot for parents they're going to be
like yeah sure you know I want parental
rights okay what new rights is this
going to give I need to know that for
myself so I stop asking this
question representative grman
thank you
chairman so we're children in family law
and of course parents would want a
parents' Bill of Rights and all those
things but we're charged with protecting
children and this cacr does have some
issues that could potentially have
teenagers being trafficked um
psychological abuse neglect um
so we're here to protect
kids and to make
sure that that we're protecting them and
this cicr has some issues in it that
gives parents I think more
rights possibly putting children In
Harm's Way
and representative this is
[Music]
not chairman Lynn's statement
notwithstanding that the statement not
otherwise serve served means this is not
hamstringing DHHS or
OCA it's debatable it's de debatable
it's and it's exactly yeah okay
representative Greg thank you Mr Mr
chairman um there's a lot in this and
it's hard to kind of gather the the
thoughts of all this um the first thing
is that children are not property um and
and and children do have rights as well
and I think the more that we push stuff
like this we take that away and and one
of their rights is is the right to
safety and regardless of what testimony
has been that they don't think that this
is going to cause a problem you know you
have to look at parents and parents that
you know um that are that are good
parents I know that if my kids are
something's happening in school that I
don't like I'm the mama bear and I'm
going to say you know what no that's
that's my child and let's talk about
this um also sometimes I have
conversations with my child and say well
this is the bigger world so let's have a
conversation about how we handle these
kind of
things there are many many parents
regardless of people that think that
this isn't a common or not that think
that they're really great parents and
they are are in fact abusive as a matter
of fact all of the abusive parents that
I have spoken with that I have met have
always said that they're good parents
they're just trying to get their kid in
line they're just trying to get their
kid to be quiet the lack of insight into
what is abuse the lack of insight into
um what is good
parenting is very very interesting I I
second representative peto's point that
that something like this is just going
to embolden the people not that are good
parent parents that understand uh that
they already have these rights but the
parents that that view their children as
property that think that they can knock
them into next week to get them to
listen that kind of stuff so I have high
concerns about the safety of children
and the rights of children with
something like
this representative Damon thank you Mr
chair I I
respectfully and I emphasize
respectfully um disagree because cuse we
already have laws in place that
protecting that are protecting the
children from the parents
who think that they're doing the right
thing but they're actually abusing the
children so the laws that protect those
children from abuse and neglect will
protect the children currently there is
very little discussion about the
protection of the good parent I'm
looking around this room and I'm seeing
parents who are good parents and they
have zero
protection this cacr should go out to
our legislative body in each and every
city in town and let them decide if they
want us as the
legislature to make this
change and give them the good parents
the protection that they
deserve thank you Mr
chairman representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman
um I'm guess I'm I'm wondering what
protection good parents need that they
don't have right now I mean currently um
um if DCF comes to my door as a parent I
can tell them to go away and their only
option is to go to court and hope that
they have enough evidence based on the
report to compel me to present my child
to them I mean right now there is a
high-profile murder
case which dcyf unfounded several times
because they didn't have that level of
evidence in order to move forward right
good parents are already protected under
the law anytime we create this enabling
legislation it doesn't impact those of
us who aren't harming our children it
only impacts the parents who don't have
the best interest of their children in
their hearts and those parents exist
when we talk about parents rights over
children's rights we
consistently affirm that we don't value
the safety and well-being and the rights
of children in this state and again I I
I noticed that there is a cut out here
theoretically and we don't really know
until there's a Supreme Court case for
physical abuse or killing your kid but
it doesn't say anything about neglecting
your kid doesn't say anything about
being required to provide medical care
to your kid when they're ill it doesn't
say anything about you know not allowing
your child to be um unsupervised at
length it doesn't say anything about any
of the other laws that we
have or guidelines that we have
requiring parents to meet the needs of
their children so under
this what we are doing is we are
enabling people to have the right to say
I can do whatever I want with my child
because I own them and we're not
allowing the state or our community
values on what is appropriate for kids
to have sway legally and I worry about
that and I I I I'm significantly worried
about those kids um especially given
that the office of the child advocate
report that came out on February I think
6th said that there were 29 children
under the age of 17 who died in New
Hampshire last year 29 kids one was
directly attributable to abuse two were
homicide several were
overdoses right maybe I think it's okay
for my 13-year-old to smoke pot and do
other things does this say that I'm
allowed to do that I don't
know I don't think we should wait for
court cases to find
out let me say and I hope also with all
due respect I fear the ever
encroaching Nanny State you may not know
but in Oregon until some time ago it was
illegal to have your child in any school
other than the public school now I would
say that is probably anti-roman Catholic
bigotry um but nevertheless this is the
state saying to parents you cannot have
your kid in a parochial school and wow
you cannot homeschool your kid and as I
watch the polarization across the
country I
fear ever overarching statism from the
left and the right and I'm suggesting
that
this before us is not so much parents
versus children as it's parents versus
an Ever overarching state so that is why
I will be voting for this amendment
anyone else
representative
Greg thank you chairman if we really
think that that this is going to protect
against abuse because of what we already
have before we start looking at
something like this that will enable
parents that are not good can we look at
what our definitions of abuse are and
put some more safeguards for children in
before we start to do this and give this
to parents um that would be much more
helpful right now we don't even have an
updated definition of abuse in this
state representative deimon thank you Mr
chair I'm reading and rereading uh the
bill in I don't see anywhere that it
says in this cacr that the parents will
own own the child the word's not used
that's number one number
two in the past we have heard testimony
time and time and time again where if
you go to a particular Public elementary
middle or high school and ask for
educational itinerary you are
denied access you are denied there is
irrefutable proof about that
denial this cacr does not in any way
manner or form allow a parent to become
a criminal and abuse their child it just
gives them a constitutional right to be
a parent it gives them the right to go
to a courtroom and say I have never
abused my child yet I am not allowed
access to my
child this is what it's all about we
have
become a society
that causes a cacr like this to become
necessary I might point out on line
18 parents have the fundamental right
and responsibility to direct the
upbringing education and share their
minor children the other bill at least
in its original form had the word
control among other ways this bill
before a 17 is a much softer uh
iteration of parental rights than the
other one representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman along
these lines while I was driving in this
morning coincidentally on the uh news
they reported a significant increase in
measles among unvaccinated children um
and it's because more and more parents
are filing uh religious exemptions
exemptions for personal philosophy and
so forth and um the increase in measles
uh is somewhat alarming and it's uh it's
it's rather new uh in a number of
decades so I just put that out there
that individual parents just don't
believe in vaccinations and right now we
see a significant uh uh uptick therefore
if this bill became law would it mean
that the state could not compel measles
vaccinations of children and would that
be to be
feared or put it the other way should we
allow the state to
compel um numbers of vaccinations of
children and that's that's kind of a
Crux issue here
representative
Perez thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to speak
um CR CR CR 17
um we keep saying that we try to protect
kids to be honest this is not protecting
kids this is taking away protecting kids
I've been saying over and over and over
again if someone who was victim when I
was little these two bills it will take
the protection of children's from abuse
of
parents and I can tell you from the
bottom of my heart that i' be 50 years
old in like couple days well a week and
a half and discards from the abuse when
I was five years old until I was 10
years
old always always going to be on me
and every time this conversation comes
out about giving more parental rights
when the parents already have
rights and then people don't have the
answers when we ask what other rights
parents want when we allow them already
to abuse children like
myself and I can tell you that I went to
a Catholic
school and the cathic school cover my
dad's abuse against me because he was a
big owner for the school to a private
school I can tell you that these two
bills have nothing good about protecting
kids and it's not giving more rights to
parents abuser parents probably going to
give them more rights to continue doing
the abuse without have a proper report
or
proper way to protect kids so for that
reason I will say let's not support
these two
bills I think we're pretty well circling
around and going over the same things
again and again is there anything new
that anybody wishes to say before we go
to the vote representative long one more
thank you Mr chairman um with respect to
divorce cases with respect to where
parents don't agree which one has that
fun fundamental right they both have the
fundamental right so I see job security
for attorneys in a judicial system in
this
we'll now move to the question the chair
moves ought to pass do I have a
second representative Nelson I heard and
saw
second next Jan Nelson I think we've
discussed it to death but I do have to
give you the right to say anything
more before we call a
rooll seeing No Hands the motion Forest
is on cac1 17 the motion is ought to
pass moved by the chair and seconded by
representative J Nelson the clerk please
call the
role jamman Pearson yes representative
long no representative disimon yes
representative
bfid representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon
no representative Connor yes
representative uh Co colum Kum yes near
Wales and representative sidel yes
Representative
grman no representative LC no
representative patrino will vote no
representative Perez absolutely no
representative Greg no representative
Fox no representative Raymond
no 6 to10 the motion fails
6-10 the chair will entertain a second
motion itl Mr chairman I uh move itl
representative Petrino moves itl and who
is to second second seconded
representative
Perez once again I have to give you an
opportunity to say something thank you
for not doing that the motion before us
is itl moved by representative patrino
and seconded by representative Perez and
please clerk call the
RO chairman
Pearson uh no representative long yes
Representative disimon no representative
bfid representative Nelson no
representative McMahon yes
representative Conor no representative
kokum
no Representative sidel
no representative
grman yes representative L yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Fox yes
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 10 to
six 10 to six it carries and would the
clerk please write the report which is
handed to me which which I hand back to
you and I will take care of the Minority
Report this ends the um exec session on
cia1
17 and I'll now open the um exec session
on
CCR
25 and I really don't think we're going
to need a lot of discussion on this
um but you may if you wish
Mr
chairman I will just put my two cents
withth it and why I am not in favor
which is I don't have a clear feeling of
where where
these uh ccrs are taking us um as
representative patrio stated we've
already got a lot on the on the book
with the federal government and with the
state government and and I'm not I guess
I'm sitting here saying no one has
articulated very well outside of the
vaccination issue as to where where we
need to go I usually say what's the
problem is this the solution and I'm not
clear what how much of a solution this
is that's why I'm where I'm at thank
you seeing nothing further would
somebody like to make a motion on cacr
move itl itl moved by representative
long second representative
perz I move to Second itl thank you any
further
discussion
um in my opinion and in the opinion of
some of my caucus uh committee caucus
this was the lesser of the two bills so
therefore having supported um in vain
the previous one I will be voting now I
will be voting itl against this one as
well because that's kind of what we
concluded last night some of us on my
caucus anything
else would the I concur yeah yeah Mr
chairman this this bill has some
dangerous language in and after this is
done I've got a scoot upstairs to
testify before a committee but I will be
back um in case you're still here um
clerk please call the role itl is the
motion on cacr 25 moved by
representative long seconded by
representative Perez clerk please call
the RO chairman Pearson uh yeah yes
representative long yes representative
ton yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative Connor yes
representative Kum yes representative
sidel yes representative
grman yes representative LC yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Fox yes
representative Raymond yes itl passes 16
to zero okay and if You' write the
report I'll look at it this concludes
the exec session on cacr 25 and it also
concludes our uh meeting for
today
e e